RAY S. PRESENT MATHIS. ARAMBULA%
CHOI CHOICE ABSENT FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HERE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN STONE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WELCOME TO THE AUGUST
THIRD HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TODAY
WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA WITH FIVE BILLS ON
CONSENT. TO START I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ALL THE STUFF. THEY
HAVE MADE POSSIBLE ARE RETURNED
TO THE CAPITAL AND OUR ABILITY
TO MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTICIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS.
DURING THE CONTINUE TO STAY AT
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WARNED
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MOUSE WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM HERE IN ROOM FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF
ANY MEMBER PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOUR W. V. R.
AND R. T. S. WITNESSES IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. THE
R. T. S. LOCATED ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE STATE CAPITOL. FOR
THOSE WITNESSES WHO WILL FOR
THOSE THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM. ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS.
FOR THE IT WOULDN'T IS WE ALSO
BE USED A MODERATED TELEPHONE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON THE BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING
HIM PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESS PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN Q. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU WERE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND AND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO. THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
WERE CALLED TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PAIN WAS WITH A
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT AREA NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO EIGHT NINE AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRYING TO HELP.
I ALSO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. FOR EACH BUILDING
PRESENTED THERE WILL BE A
MAXIMUM OF TWO WITNESSES. AND A
MAXIMUM OF TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS. THEREAFTER IF YOU WISH
TO ADD ON YOU CAN IDENTIFY
YOURSELF WITH NAME AFFILIATION.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT I THINK IT'S TIME TO
BEGAN- FIRST WE HAVE. A NUMBER
OF. MATTERS ON CONSENT WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE OH
SEVEN BY SENATOR ARCHER LET
THEM. ITEM FOUR SB TEN SIXTY
FIVE SENATOR HERTZBERG ITEM
SEVEN. SB ONE THREE FOUR ONE
SENATOR OR THE OTHER. ITEM
EIGHT SB THIRTY THREE SENATOR
NINE SIX BY SENATOR STERN. WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND PLEASE
TAKE ROLE. RED HI RES I MATHIS
MATHIS I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
FRIEDMAN. GIPSON GIFTS AND AYE
STONE STONE I. THREE FIVE. THE
MOTION WILL KERRY- HOWEVER WILL
LEAVE THE RECORD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. OKAY ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATOR BELL IS NOT
HERE YET. IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT
BILL ITEM THREE. SENATOR GLAZER.
IT'S NOT HERE YET SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON WOULD YOU PLEASE
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR IT
WAS THE OTHER ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB TWELVE FIFTY NINE AND A
THEREAFTER ITEM TO SIX SB
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR. HOWEVER
YOU'D LIKE. THANK YOU WERE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR A
TITLE- I AM PRESENTING SB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE. WHICHWILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO EXTRAPOLATE
A TASK FORCE ON MEETINGS THE
HOUSING AT THE HOUSING AND CARE
NEEDS OF LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE BLIND DISABLED OR OVER
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE
RECEIVING SUPPLEMENTAL SO
SECURITY INCOME TAX. STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL- PAYMENTS S. S. HI
AND S. S. P. BOARD AND CARE
FACILITIES PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PROVIDING HOUSING CARE
AND SUPERVISION FOR OF PEOPLE
WHO DO TO PHYSICAL OR- BEHAVIOR
ISSUES CANNOT CARE FOR
THEMSELVES. THE FACILITY IT
SERVES OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ON A
DAILY BASIS BUT DUE TO THE
LIMITED DUE TO THE DATA
LIMITATIONS. IT IS CURRENTLY
UNKNOWN WHETHER THE
AVAILABILITY OF A BOOK OF THE
BOARD AND CARE PLACEMENT HAS
BEEN KEEPING UP WITH THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIANS DISABLE AN
OLDER. ADULT POPULATIONS
EXPRESSLY THOSE WHO RECEIVE S.
S. I. N. S. S. P. BENEFITS THIS
BILL WILL MAKE AN IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARDS DEFINING THIS
LOOSE. AND PROBLEMS WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
REMOTELY WILL BE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
ASSOCIATION WHO WAS SELF INTER
DEUCE MADAM CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE
APPROPRIATE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR ABOUT SADDAM. OUR
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS LISTED HIS TYLER
WRITTEN DAY BY PHONE. ONE IN
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BOND
THAT RIVER AND GIVE A KIND OF A
HIP HOP CORRECTIVE ACTION WE
REPRESENT A FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
AND- HOW DEPARTMENT THE CROP.
PROVIDE CREDIT THINKING AT
ABOUT HEALTH AND BUT YOU
DISORDERS. THE GET PRODUCT
SUPPORT AT THE TOP NINE THUNDER
AUTO INTO HELP TACKLE CREDIT
ISSUE I WORKED IN A LOT%
BOARDING CARE ABOUT WHAT IT THE
CROP THE EIGHT WE- I HAVE A LOT.
IN COUNTY THE CROP CAL. IN OUR
THERE AND A LOT ABOUT A QUARTER
OF THE ABILITY THAN A LOT FOR
YOU. AND A THIRD OF THAT THAT
WE BE AND TWENTY TWELVE
DEMONSTRATES DOUBT ON THE- A
BUT LIKE TO URGE YOU. I FELT ON
THE BILL IN YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER IN THE- OUR
THERE ANY OF WITNESSES IN SOME
OF AB. TWO FIFTEEN. HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SAYING NON.
REMOTELY. SAYING NONE. MATT
OPERATOR SIR OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE TWO FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
YOU HAVE TO IN THE QUEUE WE GOT
A LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS IT SUCKS HANDLED
EVERYTHING SIX BED. WHICH THAT
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SIX BEDS
OR FEWER RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
RESTAURANT THE COURT AT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FOR.
WORLDWIDE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THE LIGHT%
THE MONEY HAVE DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN THE PARK.
THANK YOU. HERE WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN HERE OKAY HE ONE MOMENT.
BOTTOM LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DONNA THANK VETTING A
LOS COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AT THE PORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I DO HAVE ONE MORE THAT
JUST CUED UP. AND SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS AT
THE CENTER OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS OFFICIALLY
WORK THE PART OF THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE. YOU'RE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SAYING NONE
REMOTELY. SAYING NONE MADAM
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN Q. IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWENTY TWELVE FIFTY NINE.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. HEARING
NONE MISTER GIBSON WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVALED BEHALF OF CENSURE
O'DONNELL. Q. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE TAKE.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS RAY YES HI RES
HI MATT THIS. MATHIS I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI FRIEDMAN. GIPSON
GIVES AN AYE STONE STONE HI THE
CURRENT COUNT IN THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. VERY GOOD WE
WILL LEAVE THE RECORD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. MR GET SOMEBODY
LIKE TO PRESENT ON SB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE. SURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HOW TODDLE- TODAY I
PRESENT AS S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
FOR THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES-
DISBURSEMENT BO. I'M THE BUS
BILL- WHICH- MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES BUT DOES NOT BUT DOES
ALSO INCLUDE MORE SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS NOT NORMALLY PURSUED
IN THIS OMNIBUS BILL. BUT IN
LIGHT OF COKE NOW FOR. AND THE
PROSPECT OF FUTURE WILDFIRES
THAT COULD- CALL AS EVACUATIONS
OF SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RECEIVED. BELIEVED IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THIS CRITICAL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION MOVES THIS
YEAR. THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
OUTLINES ONE REQUIRES.
SPECIFIED US SPECIFIC RESIDENTS
FACILITIES AND ALL ADULT
DAYCARE PROGRAMS TO ADOPT
EMERGENCY DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
PLAN. EXTENDS THE LIMIT LIKE
EXAMINATION AN APPOINTMENT
PROGRAM THE L. E. A P.
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM PILOT UNTIL
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CODIFIES THE DEFINITION OF
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE WHICH ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PROVIDE
ADVOCACY AND REPRESENTATION ON
BEHALF. OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITY CORRECT CROSS
REFERENCE TO EXISTING CODE TO
CLARIFY THE PROCESS FOR
APPOINTMENTS. AND OF AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES. I ALSO HAVE
NOTED THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
WORKED EXTREMELY HARD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO RESOLVE ALL
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS AT ISSUE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND PASS OUT OF SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE ON IT ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MEMBERS
MADAM CHAIRMAN YOU ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR
SB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR HOW TOTAL.
THANK MOTIONS. ARE THERE ANY
AND YOUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS
CATHY SANDERLING FROM COUNTY
WILL FOR DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
BY PHONE. ACTUALLY THAT WAS ON
ANOTHER BILL. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES LISTED. ANYWAY THIS
IS HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES-
TESTIFY REMOTELY. SEEING NONE
ADAM OPERATOR THE AT THEIR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BOTTOM LINE. LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THAT
AND ZERO. I HAVE NO LINE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THING NINE HERE IN
THE CONFERENCE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SAYING THE WITNESSES
REMOTELY MADAM OPERATOR THEY'RE
ANY. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR AND Q. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BORDERLINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
CALL I HAD. I'M ACTUALLY AT THE
PORT- SORRY I WOULDN'T CALL ON
THE NETWORK THOUGH WITH THE
ACCOUNT ON THE BALLOT MENTAL
DISABILITIES ORDER OF THE OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN YOU AND
I HAVE. I HAVE NO FURTHER I
THINK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD MR GET SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WILL
RESPECTFUL ACT ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON IT SB TWELVE SIXTY FOR
A TITLE. ZERO SEC ROOM THE
MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS RADIUS HI RES HI
MATT THIS MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI FRIEDMAN. GIPSON
GETZEN AYE STONE STONE HI THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO.
THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE RECORD
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU AND NOW SENATOR BELL ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB. EIGHT NINE
TWELVE. MOVIE BILL SECOND.
SURE
MEMBERS THANK YOU KNOW. BECAUSE
I RECOGNIZE WITH ALL OVER AND.
WE WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS
DURING THE BUDGET- ON DEALING
WITH THIS ISSUE- I WANT TO
THANK LEADERSHIP OF BOTH HOUSES
IN ADMINISTRATION FOR COMING TO
AN AGREEMENT ON THE BUDGET
WHICH PROTECTS FOSTER YOUTH AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE FOR YEAR.
ALLOWS THEM TO RECOVER- FROM
THE CO ED PANDEMIC NOW. IT
HAPPENED THAT THE AGREEMENT WAS
FIVE DAYS BEFORE THERE ARE
BENEFITS EXPIRED. A REAL NAIL
BITER. FOR THE FOSTER KIDS- BUT
WE GOT TO AGREEMENT SO WITH
THIS BILL BASICALLY DOES IS IF
THAT EVER HAPPENS AGAIN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PROTOCOL THAT
THEY GO THROUGH. SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
AGAIN OKAY I ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE SABRINA FORTE.
YES I FORGOT TO INTRODUCE MY
WILL PRIMARY WITNESS FOR DAVE
THE CHUCK CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
I BELIEVE THIS ON THE LINE OKAY
THANK YOU YEAH GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU CHAIR READ THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
TO ANOTHER ABOUT. AUTHOR IN THE
IMPORTANT. AND FOR YOUR ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVINGTHE
LIVES OF YOUTH AND DOCTOR CARE
I'M BRING A FOUR K. AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER. HE
WALKED AND HER WHAT THE COUPON
THERE OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
WHICH CREATED CALIFORNIA'S
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE PROGRAM IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND WE NOW
PROBABLY CO SPONSOR AT THE NINE
TWELVE. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PRACTICE CREATED BY CALLED THE
NINETEEN HAVE BROUGHT TO LIGHT
THE URGENT NEED TO ENACT
POLICIES THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
TRANSITION AGE FACTOR YOU ARE
ABLE TO DATE THE- PEOPLE IN THE
COURT OF PLACEMENT DURING. AN
EMERGENCY. I CAN MARCH.
CALIFORNIANS BUCKET HOW
EDUCATIONAL AND EMPLOYMENT
REPORT THAT. CUT THEIR PROGRAM
OUR CLOTHES COMPLETE TO COMPLY
WITH SOCIAL THAT NAME AND AT
HOME ORDERS. YOU THINK DOCTOR
CARE WILL PICK IT VULNERABLE
HEART. ACCORDING THE POT THE
QUICK SURVEY NEARLY 65% A
TRANSITION H. PROCTOR YOU THE
APPOINTMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC
NEARLY ONE IN FIVE REPORTED
THAT THEY HAD RUN OUT OF FOOD.
23% REPORTED HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND ONLY 37% FELT
THAT THEY SUPPORTED SUPPORTED
ADULT TO RELY ON DURING THE
CRISIS. AT THE OTHER BELL HAD
NOTED. BUT BUT- THIRD CARE. FOR
HUNDREDS OF TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
AND YOU CAN NO LONGER MEET THE
USUAL PARTICIPATION
REQUIREMENTS DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. WE NEED ACTION THAT
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT WITH BOND.
AT THE NINE TWELVE IF NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS APPLY TO ALL YOU
WHO TURNS TWENTY ONE DURING THE
CALL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
THAT YOU CAN FOSTER CARE ARE
PROTECTED DURING FUTURE
EMERGENCIES. I THE NINE FIVE
ALLOW OF THE THINGS THAT SMALL
NUMBER OF YOU RETURNS TWENTY
ONE AND A- FOSTER CARE IN THE
WEEKS BEFORE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. TO REENTER
DOCTOR CARE AND RECEIVED
SUPPORT TO THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR. I THINK. OPEN SURE
THE DEEP PROTECTION PICKING
AUTOMATICALLY DURING FUTURE
DATE THE MARGIN PLEASE FOR THE
TRANSITION AID YOU DO NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT GETTING CARE DUE
TO AGE. AND ABILITY TO MEET
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS. IN
THE MIDDLE OF A CRISIS THAT. SO
MUCH FOR YOUR AND CAN. WE WERE.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND I
NOW TO AND YOU DEATH IDEA
PRINTER HOUSE. A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A CHECK THE ACCURACY
WITH A JENNY HOW OFTEN ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS. OF EIGHTY NINE
TWELVE. WE HAVE PROVIDED DIRECT
SERVICES TO KIND OF ON THE BOX
YOUTH IN LOS ANGELES AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. ABOUT A MAJOR PART OF
WHAT FUELS MY WORK. ALSO MY
ONLY EXPERIENCE IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. I OFTEN MAKE MAKE
FUN OF THE FACT THAT IN PART OF
THE- OLD SCHOOL FOSTER CARE
CREAM. WHERE WE WOULD LITERALLY
BE WALKED INTO COURT ROOM OR
EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY. WITH BLACK
TRASH BAGS BILL WITH A FEW ONLY
BELONGING THAT EVER BELONG TO A.
IN A FEW LEGAL WORDS WILL BE
MUMBLE AND THEN THE JUDGE WOULD
LOOK AT YOU IF THEY GRADUATION
AND NOW LET'S GO. WE WISH YOU
THE BEST OF LUCK. THEN YOU'D
WALK OUT OF COURT. IT MIGHT BE
A SOCIAL WORKER. AND THE
REALITY WOULD HATE IMMEDIATE.
OFFICIALLY ALONE. THE PROCESS
OF BREAKING OUT OF SERVICES
THAT ARE YOU CAN BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AND THOMAS I THINK.
IT'S NOT JUST LOSING RESOURCES.
IT'S LITERALLY THE ONLY SUPPORT
THAT WE COME TO RELY ON
EVERYTHING. ONE CAN ONLY
IMAGINE HOW SCARY WOULD BE AGE
OUT DURING A PANDEMIC LIKE THE
ONE WE CURRENTLY PAY. ARIANNA
APPEARS IN PAUL MCCLOSKEY. TURN
TWENTY ONE ON MARCH FIFH IN
OUR CASE WAS CLOSED ON A DAY.
SHE LOST HER JOB AT THE CARE
GIVER OF IT. IN THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH. AND HAS YET TO FIND A
NEW JOB EVEN THOUGH SHE'S BEEN
LOOKING. SHE WAS GONNA
SUPERVISE INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAM. BACK TO FIND A NEW AND
CHEAPER APARTMENT. AND SAID IN
A DAILY STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN
HER HOUSING. AND MAKE ENDS MEET.
SB NINE TWELVE ESTABLISHES THE
PROVIDE THE BILL BECAUSE- AGING
OUT THERE THE STATE OF.
POSSIBLY NOT RICH IN TRANSITION
THANK SUCH A PRACTICE. ANY
PATIENTS THE STATE THAT THEY
CAN WEATHER THE STORM WITH
SUPPORT AND TAKING THAT SERVICE
THE- FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
ARE JUST OR- I'M ANTI NINE
TWELVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
HAD LISTED ARIANNA CLAY- JUST
SAID WE ARE A TESTIFIED THAT IN
HER STEAD IS THAT CORRECT.
CORRECT THANK YOU SO MUCH. ARE
TERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE ONE TWELVE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SAYING
NONE. REMOTELY SEEING NONE.
MADAM OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY.
IS IT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN Q. AND LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVER
THE LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REBECCA DEVELOP NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JESSICA
BARTOLO WITH ELECTION
CAMPGROUND ON POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KATHLEEN KNOCKED ON
REPRESENTING BURTON ADVOCATE.
JOHN CORD. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MCCORMICK CHILDREN WALKED IN
OUR CALIFORNIA. ON THE BILL AND
JOHN BEFORE. THANK YOU LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING ERIC EIGHTY AVOID THE
NEARING STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THE ANNUALLY THAN BOB FROM
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHILE THE BILL
IS LARGELY OUTSIDE OF OUR PROVE
YOU WE DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THAT. FOR INSURING THE
COURT HAVE EXPRESSED
JURISDICTION TO CONTINUE DURING
THE CAKE THANK. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MARTHA GRAHAM REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF THE MEN DID WITH THE
FUNDING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN YOU LAND COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE COP
OUT OF LOS ANGELES AND
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE I
THE CALIFORNIA LINE THE CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING OF THE
PARTIAL WITH THE USOC SEVENTY
ARE. THANK YOU. Q. AND I HAVE
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. IT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOU'RE
IN THE HEARING ROOM I'VE SEEN
NONE. MOSTLY I'VE SEEN NONE.
I'M ADAM OPERATOR THEY'RE ANY
WITNESSES IN Q. IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE TWELVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO LIFE THANK YOU AT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU. WHAT SENATOR BILL I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FORWARD INSURING THAT
OLDER FOSTER YOU HAVE ADEQUATE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES IS VITAL
TO ENSURING A SUCCESSFUL
FUTURE. WE KNOW THAT OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH FACE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES SUCH AS ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS AND
BARRIERS TO COMPLETING HIGHER
EDUCATION. THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED AMERICANS
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE AND OUR
FOSTER YOUTH ARE NO EXCEPTION.
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED REDUCED
EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND ARE FACING
THE CONSEQUENCESOF COVERT
NINETEEN WITHOUT THE
TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE RECEIVE FROM THEIR
PARENTS. I'M PROUD OF THE
INVESTMENTS. CALIFORNIA'S MAY
TO SUPPORT THESE YOU BUT
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE THAT CAN BE
DONE SB NINE TWELVE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN ENSURING THAT
OUR FOSTER YOUTH HAVE THE
SUPPORT TO MEET THEIR GOALS AND
ACHIEVE SUCCESS I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN SO THAT YOUR BILL FOR
ALL THE WORK FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER YOUTH. I'D LIKE TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SAYING NONE CENTRE BELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OF YES I JUST
ORIGINAL VOTE ON THIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE TAKE
ROOM THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS RADIUS HI RES HI
MATT THIS. MATHIS I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GIPSON. GETZEN AYE STONE
STONE HI THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO.
THE MOTION PASSES THANK YOU
SENATOR. ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWELVE THIRTY TO SENATOR
GLAZERS. LITTLE DRAGON. FOR
MORE GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION AND
THE SECOND THANK YOU AND I'LL
MAKE MY REMARKS- BRIEF. I WANT
TO. SAY THIS BILL IS ABOUT-
STUDENT PARENTSON CAL WORKS-
THEIR JUGGLING A LOT OF THINGS
BEING A PARENT- TRYING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. AND SO THE BILL
TRIES TO DO TWO THINGS TO HELP
THOSE STUDENTS ONE IS- IF
THEY'RE MAKING CONTINUED
PROGRESS IN THEIR EDUCATION. IT
MAKES THEM ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
FULL BENEFITS. AND TO THERE'S A
REAL QUIRKINESS IN REGARD TO
PAYMENT FOR BOOKS- COUNTY
REIMBURSEMENT TENDS TO HAPPEN
LATER IN THE SEMESTER. SOME
KIDS ARE AVOIDING THAT
OBLIGATION OR WORRIED ABOUT IT
SO THEY'RE NOT GETTING THEIR
BOOKS TO START THIS WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO GET THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE ONLY. SO THOSE
ARE TWO KEY ISSUES THERE- THE
COMMITTEE AT RAISE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT- PART TIME
STUDENTS- GET ME AN ELIGIBLE
LINE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO. WORKING
THAT THAT ISSUE THROUGH- AND
HAPPY TO ADVANCE THAT IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS IF
YOU'RE COMMITTEE IS ACCEPTABLE
WITH ACT. AND SO WITH THAT-
WELL I DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES
WHO OF BEEN GREAT AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS FROM THE
START- I BELIEVE ON THE PHONE
LINES KEVIN. A SLIMY AND FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION AND
JOANNA REYES WALTON THAT PHD
CANDIDATE UCLA WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY. THANK YOU-
MISTRUST LINE IN I KNOW YOU ON
THE CELL STEPS. YOUR FIRST. HI
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE OF
GROWTH I GUESS I'M ON SO- GOOD
GOOD AFTERNOON TO. WARNING TO
EVERYBODY THIS IS THE BILL. IN
RESPONSE TO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY PEOPLE TO BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT. YEAH WE DID WE DID
WE LIVE IN A KNOWLEDGE BASED
ECONOMY IN THE LAWN AND NOT IS
BASED ECONOMY YOU NEED A THE
DEGREE. THE FACTS SHOW THAT IF
YOU HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
YOU MAKE ANNUALLY THREE TWO
THOUSAND ZERO IF YOU HAVE A BE
A YOU MAKE SIXTY THOUSAND A
YEAR. THIS BILL WOULD BASIS
SIMPLIFY THE SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE
TO GO TO COLLEGE SPECIAL DURING
THE PANDEMIC. THIS SIMPLIFIES
THE WAY. THAT PEOPLE GET THE
BOOKS. THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE ANALYSIS. AND THE BILL HAS
SUPPORT FROM AN- VERSION. AND
ACCOUNTING. WE ORIGINAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BUT I DO OTHER.
TO WHERE RAY AS WELL IS ON THE
PHONE THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. ONE CAN THIS IS
JOANNA LAST FALL CURRENT SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO YOU AGAIN ABOUT MY
SUPPORT AT THE TWELFTH GRADE
KILL- AS ABSENT ELECTION AND
PHD CANDIDATE UCLA I'M ALSO A
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT AND A SINGLE MOTHER. SO
WHEN I RETURNED TO SCHOOL TO DO
PHD IT WOULD NOT WAY OUT OF
FINANCIAL. AND DENTIST
BEGINNING A THE NEW PATH BUT
LIKE MY- BUT IF I STARTED MY
EDUCATE. I THINK A LOT OF
FINANCIAL. FUNDING GRAD STUDENT.
WORKING BY JOHN. AND DIFFERENT
NOT AFTER FOR FIVE. AND OF THE
PARK LINE. AT MY VERY STEM
HOUSING APARTMENT CURRENTLY
PERCENT OF MY STIPEND. SO LIKE
MANY OF MY FELLOW PEERS I'M A
SINGLE MOTHER COLOR TRYING TO
SUCCEED AT SCHOOL. AT THE
PARENT AND I'M ON WELFARE. I'M
CALPERS BY THE CHRISTIAN TWO
PEOPLE KILLED MY CHILD AND
MYSELF. AND EVERYTHING HELP CUT
TO THAT ACCOUNT BECAUSE IT
DEPENDS COVERAGE TO MY NUMBERS
EXTREMELY. I WOULD LIKE FOR CAL
WORK AND BUT I WAS DENIED AND I
DON'T WHY STILL. I'M DEPARTMENT
THE POINT BENEFIT WHICH ARE TO
IT THE RESPONSE OKAY AND UPON
CA. I'M SPEAKING WITH
PATRICK EXACTLY BENEFITS I'VE
LEARNED THAT ON CAL WORKS COME
EVEN MORE BAY AREA. I WILL HELP
LOOKED AT YET I THINK IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR. BOB. AT THE TIME
THAT ARE SCHEDULE CHANGE EVERY
TIME I TAKE A DIFFERENT CLASS
AND A HUNDRED SINGLE CHANGING
REGARDING. RECORDS ONCE MY
INSURED MONITORING OPENED HER
UP TO GET LOOK AT THE- THAT BY.
DISDAIN FOR WELFARE RECIPIENTS.
YOU COULD NOT MUCH OF THE TO
STEP PUT ON THE IN MY P. WHO
TOLD THE COURT KNOCKED. AND
PRISCILLA EDUCATE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF TIME TO NAVIGATE THE
COUNTRY CAT. NOT TRACKING SB.
UNTIL DON'T YOUR FIFTEEN
CATHOLIC MISCALCULATION
ELECTION THE BENEFIT TO CALVET
AND BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON AND TO
AT THE PUMP WITH THE ABILITY
AND THE ABOUT THE SYSTEM FOR
GOOD DEEP STUDENT A GOOD PARENT.
AND WHAT WOULD. I URGE THE
COURT BECAUSE TO EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU FOR YOU. IN SUPPORT ON IN
Q. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
TO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE'RE
GONNA WIND FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF AT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. Q. I
AM THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN THE PARK.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JESSICA
BARCELONA WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY THE COURT. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KEVIN AND GIRLFRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG THE COURT.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT IF YOU DO WHAT THE
TEAMS VOEPEL TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
SENATOR ORANGE IS THE ACT WE
SPOKE. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATHY
SENATOR L<c.cyan>G WHAT THE COUNTY</c>
WELFARE DIRECTORS THAT SHE CHEN
IN SUPPORT. Q. AND I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THAT
TIME. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWELVE AB SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
SAYING NON HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SAYING NONE REMOTELY MADAM
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE THIRTY TWO AND Q. I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO LIFE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU THAT'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. HEARING NONE CENTER
GLAZER WAS IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT THAT THAT THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR AND ADDED
TECHNOLOGY IN THE DIFFICULT
TIMES RAN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL. I WANT TO THANK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION FOR CO SPONSORING
IT. THIS BILL OR RELIEVE
PRESSURE ON STUDENTS PARENTS
ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES. AND ALLOW OUR
CAL WORKS APPLICANTS AND
RECIPIENTS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND
PROFESSIONAL GOALS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO WORK ON
THE PAYMENT STRUCTURE WITH
APPROPRIATIONS. YES THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE TAKE ROLE. THE
MOTION IS THE BEST
APPROPRIATIONS RAY YES HI RES
HI MATT THIS. MATHIS I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
HI GETZEN. GETZEN AYE STONE
STONE HI THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU. THANK NUMBERS FOR
PATIENCE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR OUR WE'RE GOING TO ADD ON-
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HI THE FINAL VOTE IS
FIVE OR SIX ZERO THOSE BILLS
ARE OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS. ON
FILE ITEM FIVE SB TWELVE FIFTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
HI THE FINAL VOTE IS SIX ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM SIX
SB. EIGHT TWELVE SIXTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
HI THE FINAL VOTE IS SIX ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU. ALL
VERY MUCH OR BEING HERE FOR
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THIS
CONCLUDES THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE HEARING.